피디를 하면서 출연까지 했습니다
요런 거를 이제 계속 어필을 하면서
그래서 요즘 저희 분장시키시는 거겠죠?
너희들도 할 수 있어
10회 때 이게 슬슬 잘 되고 있으니까 슈커님이 여기 와서
숟가락을 얹어 주시면서
숟가락
야 무슨 터졌다 진짜
나 그때가 200만은 됐어요
인사하겠습니다
인사하실 거예요?
애교 많이 컸다
할게 할게
인사할 거야
다리는 꽂지 마시고
차렷 인사
안녕하세요
어 한 명이 인사하는 척만 하시는 거 같은데
학생?
학부모입니다
자 이거를 하나 맞혀보세요
땡땡
뚱뚱니니?
제가 끌어낼게요
선생님 학생이 건방진데요?
우범생 우리 슈커 학생이 한번 맞혀볼까요?
물린니니?
맞지 맞지 정확하잖아요
대황니니라고
국장을 다스리는 국모라고 해야 될까요?
그렇게 불러주시더라고요
저는 그런 생각이 없었는데
그래서 감사하게도
오늘은 우리 주알못 여러분들께 주식 강의를 해야 되는데
오늘은 특별히 사회생활에 대해서
한번 여러분들께 강의를 해보려고 합니다
대황니니가 과연 슈커 친구들에서 어떻게 살아나 봤는지
어떻게 본부장 자리에까지 오를 수 있었는지
궁금하시죠?
와 궁금합니다
대표 자료조서 아니고요? 대표 자료조서?
그래요 코칠찌린니니가 어떻게 대황니니가 되냐고
그 얘기 해주세요
사실 우리 슈카사장님이 열심히 이끌어 주신 것도 당연히 크고 사회생활을 어떻게 해야 주식생활까지 이어지는 이런 것들에 대해서 제가 한번 정리를 한번 해드리고자 합니다.
구호를 힘차게 외치고 시작해보도록 하겠습니다.
기다려라 슈카쌤 될 수 있다.
알상무.
저 구호 누가 만들었니? 백윤이 만들었어?
저 아닙니다.
PD님 학생 좀 바꿔주세요.
아니 아니 물어볼 수 있지.
니니쌤에게 뭔가를 좀 배워가야겠다는 그런 의지 그런 거를 좀 보여주시면 좋을 것 같아요.
사장님인데 배워갈 게 뭐가 있냐고.
잡돌이를 잘하더라고.
근데 옆에 위드 나무중권은 뭔가요?
아 나무중권 같은 경우는 사실 이 니니쌤 조회수가 무려 36만이 나왔어요.
이게 올린 지가 한 2주 정도 됐거든요.
솔직히 저도 이 정도로 잘 될 줄은 몰랐어요.
니니쌤이 잘 돼서 사실 슈카쌤을 한 1, 2년 했거든요.
슈카쌤으로 안 들어오던 광고가 니니쌤.
한 회차 만에 광고가 들어왔습니다.
일은 1년간 슈카가 하고.
제가 슈카쌤 몇 개 올렸는지 알아요?
그래도 사회생활이군요.
사실 어떤 니니의 주식 강의보다는 카메라 구독에 관해서
그 댓글이 거의 한 1,300개가 달렸나요?
1,300개 중에 700개가 뚱니입니다.
아니 그러니까 지금 인생 역대 최대 몸무게인데
이거를 제가 빼기 시작하면 뚱니 타이틀을 못 가져가거든요.
그래서 제가 억지로 사실 좀 못 가져가거든요.
남우증권을 위해서라도 비주얼 관리를 해야겠다.
아무튼 우리 윤병원 대표님 감사드리고요.
어? 대표님 이름인가요?
NH투자증권 대표님 이름 정도는 기본으로 알아두시는 게 인지상정 아니고요.
대표님이 뭐라고요?
윤병원 대표님입니다.
그분 같은 경우는 LG투자증권 거쳐서 대표이상까지.
자기 대표한테는 저런 거 없고 남녀사 대표한테는 아주 줄줄이.
그리고 이 남우증권이 UXUI도 굉장히 편하지만
얼마 전에 IMA 선정이 됐지 않습니까?
ISA, 연금, ELS 채권 이런 것들을
이 남우 어플에서 올인원으로 투자를 하실 수 있습니다.
할 수 있으니까 굉장히 편하게 할 수 있다는 점.
여러분들은 모르시겠지만 NH증권이 엄청나게 큰 증권사입니다.
그러니까 규모가 엄청나.
규모가 엄청나게 큰 증권사예요.
거기 면접 봤어요?
예전에 인수했던 회사는 본 적이 있어요.
그럼 서류 떨어진 겁니까?
아, 그쵸.
당연한 얘기를.
NH는 우리나라 손꼽히는 규모의 증권사라고 보시면 됩니다.
그래서 IMA 이런 것까지 규모가 크고까지 다 하는구나.
자본금 규모가 되기 때문에 그것들을 다 할 수 있는 거예요.
오, 갑자기 슈가쌤으로 바뀌었습니다.
작은 증권사였어요.
갑자기 슈가쌤.
규모가 안 돼서.
자, 아무튼 이번 콘텐츠는 NH나무 증권과 함께 하는데
오늘 사실 제가 강의할 거는 슬기로운 사회생활입니다.
니니가 본부장까지 올라올 수 있었던 이유를 사실 많이 궁금해하세요.
슈카님은 모르시겠지만 저희 직원분들이 어떻게 하면 연봉 올릴 수 있냐.
은근히 궁금해하더라고요.
맞습니다. 궁금합니다.
평판이 사실 가장 중요했다.
니니가 항상 성실하게 앉아있고 항상 또 사람들한테 잘하고
그랬기 때문에 주변 사람들이 아마 슈카님에게
아, 니니라는 친구가 정말 일을 열심히 하고 일을 잘하고 그런 친구다라는
어떤 이야기들을 해주시면서 슈카님이 아마 슈카 친구들로 제가 이직을 할 수 있지 않았나.
니니를 데려오려고 하니까 주변에서 와서
그, 군기반장입니다.
그러고 있었어요.
아, 진짜로. 거짓말 하나 없이.
군기 잡는 애면 괜찮겠다.
아, 잠깐만. 군기반장으로 제가 간 거였어요?
이제 알았습니다.
제가 이직할 수 있었던...
선생님.
아, 군기였어요?
사실 본부장이라는 게...
본부장이라는 이름은 제가 본부장이라고 주장을 하면 됩니다.
우리 슈카 친구들 중소기업 같은 경우는 어떤 직급에 따라 큰 차이가 없어요.
굉장히 수평한 구조이기 때문에 오늘부터 본부장 하겠습니다.
오늘부터 대리하겠습니다. 하면은 슈카님이 그래, 너 하고 싶은 거 해.
라고 해주시기 때문에.
근데 그때는 직원이 다섯 명.
나만 할 수 있는 일.
제가 코믹스 팀의 팀장으로 있지 않습니까?
저는 여기서 어떻게 살아남았느냐.
저는 사실 이 코믹스 팀의 PD로 들어왔어요.
근데 어느 순간 제가 얼굴을 까고.
그래서 제 얼굴이 돌아다니고 있더라고요.
PD를 하면서 출연까지 했습니다.
이런 거를 이제 계속 어필을 하면서.
그래서 요즘 저희 분장시키시는 거죠?
너희들도 할 수 있어.
사실 저도 처음부터 원했던 바는 전혀 아니고.
채널을 만들었어.
근데 슈카님도 바빠.
출연할 수 있는 사람이 없어.
그래서 사실 제가 어쩔 수 없이 출연을 하게 됐는데.
다행히도 일이 또 잘 풀려서.
지금은 또 이렇게 나무중권에서 니니쌤에게 광고도 주시고.
슈카 쌤에게는 안 들어오는 광고가.
들어왔지 않습니까?
다 키워도 소용이 없어요.
코믹스라는 채널이 옛날에 슈카코믹스였잖아요.
내가 왜 만들었었냐면.
주변에 다른 유튜버 친구들이.
서브채널 만들면 짭짤하다.
그래서 서브채널 만들었어요.
근데 우리는 친구들이니까.
직원들하고 하자.
너 할래? 너 할래?
다섯 명 밖에 없어요.
근데 여긴 싫다 그러고.
여기 싫다 그러고.
거의 막 끄집어내듯이.
와서 하자.
재밌을 거야.
아 이것도 기억에 조작이 있습니다.
자네는.
뭐만 얘기하면.
모투쇼라는 프로그램.
이거 어떻게 시작하는지.
아십니까?
저와 루시아가.
회사에서 아무도.
우리에게 일을 주지 않고.
우리 뭐 하지?
하다가 저희끼리.
팟캐스트를 시작한 거예요.
10회 때.
이게 슬슬 잘 되고 있으니까.
슈카님이 여기 와서.
숟가락을 얹어 주시면서.
숟가락.
무슨 터졌다 진짜.
나 그때가 200만은 됐어요.
숟가락을 얹어 주신 덕분에.
폭발적으로 잘 된 거죠.
돈을 벌어와야 되는데.
맨날 회의하고.
고민하고 하다가.
안 되겠다.
그냥 우리가.
출연해서.
우리 거라도 만들자.
라고 하면서.
사실 시작된 거고.
본인이 할 일이 없으면.
할 일을 만들자.
회사에서 일을 안 주면.
내가 이 회사에서.
필요할 것 같은 일을.
하면 된다.
어쨌든 니니가 본부장까지.
올라올 수 있었던 이유.
1번.
자기주장.
2번.
나만 할 수 있는 일.
3번.
군기를 잘 잡았다.
네 암튼.
자 요 중에서.
우리 백이훈 학생.
어떤 거를 본인.
승진 포인트로.
잡고 싶으세요?
2번을 해야 될 것 같습니다.
대체하지 못하는.
나만 할 수 있는 일.
우리 기훈 PD가.
틈새시장을 잘 잡았어요.
슈카님도 바쁘고.
안상문님도 바쁘고.
그 틈을 타서 본인이.
이제 얼굴을 팍 알리면서.
그리고 개인 채널 살짝 끼워놓고.
그렇지.
적재적소에 본인 브랜딩을.
상당히 잘했다.
그 개인 채널.
법인으로 연결돼 있죠?
제가 옛날에 회사 다닐 때.
그런 거 다 잘렸어요.
아니 왜 옆에 내가 피해자가 있어.
지금 백이훈 채널.
1.7만.
성장을 굉장히 잘하고 있거든요.
3만 넘을 때.
누가 회사에다가.
나 제보해서.
5만 넘을 때.
감사팀에서 연락 왔어요.
저희 감사팀 따로 있으니까.
오늘부터 니가.
감사팀 직원이야.
제가.
회사에 지금.
자기 SNS 하는.
직원들이 상당히 많이 늘었습니다.
우리는 그러면.
얼마가 기준이죠?
견제에 커져.
아 견제할 수 있습니까?
왜냐면.
지금 알상무님 같은 경우는.
4.9만.
그리고 머니코믹스가 4.9만.
회사 계정보다.
알상무 계정이 많습니까?
뭐 이런 회사가 다 있어?
백이훈.
1.2만.
조코 PD.
30명.
30명 계십니까?
30명은 마음껏 해.
괜찮아요.
자유롭게 해 30명.
공식.
저건.
없습니까?
아 슈카월드 11만입니다.
아 슈카월드.
아 우리도 있지 그래.
가끔 뭐 올리죠.
근데 조회수가 잘 안 나옵니다.
연봉을 올리는 것도 중요해요.
사실 제 생각에는.
주식 투자도 중요하지만.
이 절대 금액.
연봉을 좀 올리면서.
시드가 좀 커야.
투자에 그대로 반영이 되기 때문에.
회사 생활을 잘하는 게.
저는 가장.
중요하다고 생각을 하고.
자 월급을 받아서.
내가 어디에 쓸 것이냐.
저처럼 주식 투자에.
몰빵을 할 것이냐.
아니면.
뭐 예금을 할 것이냐.
이런 것들을 생각할 수 있겠죠.
근데 그런 것들을 나누기 전에.
일단은.
제 차 아시죠?
네.
13년도 구형 투싼.
대회차.
이미지 메이킹.
아 따로 있습니까?
집에 가면은.
아 못 봤어요?
문 위로 열리는 거?
와 배신.
못 봤구나.
아 배신감.
저는 차에 대한.
욕심이 일단 없고.
그 돈을 아껴서.
주식에 투자합니다.
근데 사실.
우리 사장님만 봐도 아시잖아요.
검섬의 끝판왕.
사장님도 사실.
그 똥차에.
끌고 다니는 이유 뭐예요.
그렇게 놀림 받으면서.
아무도 안 놀려.
그냥 너만 몰라서 그래.
그래도 약간 그런 거 있지 않습니까.
내가 그래도 슈칸데.
슈카가 뭔데.
뭔데 그게.
내일 일요일 밤.
4만 명의 시청자를 보는 남자.
나 스타인데.
꼭 만 원 이후도 안 되는 숫자인데.
5만 원 봅니다.
죽고 있어요.
아 죄송합니다.
어쨌든 투자를 하려고 해도.
총알이 있어야 되고.
그 총알을 만드는 게.
결국 근로소득이다.
이 말입니다.
자 우리 기훈님.
사회 초년생부터.
사실 차근차근 투자를 하셔가지고.
집도 사시고.
기훈이 빌딩 샀다며요.
저는.
비유를 하자면.
나무꾼처럼.
열심히.
투자를.
정석적으로.
니니 팀장님처럼.
레버리지 이런 거 안 쓰고.
꾸준히 투자해서.
일궈낸.
저의.
보금자리입니다.
하고 슈카쌤.
아 그렇죠.
슈카쌤으로 사실.
마인드를 굉장히 많이 배웠다.
슈카님 덕분에.
우리가 또 그런.
건전한 투자 마인드를.
또 가져왔지 않습니까.
맞습니다.
자 그러면 그 투자를.
실제적으로 어떻게 할 것이냐.
저는 이제 뭐.
레버리지 미수.
이런 시절을 지나서.
이제 저는 정말로.
안전하고.
정말 착한 매매.
곧버스?
필요하면.
적립식 매매가 있잖아요.
이게 뭐냐면.
요즘에 굉장히 잘 나오는 게.
나무 어플 들어가시면.
소수점 매매 모으기라는 게 있어요.
100만 원, 200만 원이야.
너무 비싸.
그러면 쪼개가지고.
내가 뭐 0.몇 줄을.
차곡차곡 일주일에 하나씩 산다.
내가 월급 들어올 때마다.
소액으로.
투자 습관을 들이는 겁니다.
매일 살 수도 있나요?
그럼요.
매일도 괜찮고.
저 같은 경우는.
일주일에 한 번씩.
몇 십만 원.
이런 식으로 이제.
투자를 하거든요.
그리고.
나무 어플에 들어가시면.
제가 굉장히 좀 보고.
충격받았던 서비스가 있습니다.
그게 뭐냐면.
차분이라는 서비스인데요.
이름이 차분인가요?
왜 차분일까요?
차트.
아 분석.
이게 뭐냐면.
투운사 안 따도 돼요.
야 따.
왜냐하면.
아 나 진짜 안 따도 될 것 같아.
왜냐하면 여기서.
차트 분석을 해주는데.
예를 들면.
아 요거는 이제 120.
맨날 그 알상무님.
잘난 척하는 거죠.
180선이고.
삼각수렴하고.
여기서 뭐.
헤드 앤 숄더고.
뭐 기영이고.
맨날 그런 거 하잖아요.
축하님이랑 알상무님.
이걸로 엄청 잘난 척을 해요.
근데.
사실 내가 나무 증권에 들어가서.
차분이를 보면.
이 친구가.
그 차트 분석을.
다 해줘요.
이동 평균선이라든지.
내가 이렇게 설정한 값을.
어느 정도 가이드를 준다는 거.
그 AI로 다 된다는 게.
일단 저는 너무 좋았고.
그리고 AI 에이전트라는.
서비스가 있는데.
요거 같은 경우는.
저희 차트 보면서.
맨날 우리 종토방에서만.
우리끼리 어떻게 할까 하는데.
요거는 AI 에이전트가.
종목에 대해서.
지금 어떤 뉴스가 있고.
어떤 이슈가 있는지.
요런 것들을 쫙 정리해주는.
고런 서비스이기 때문에.
투자도 똑똑하게 해야 됩니다.
여러분들이.
뭐 요런 서비스들을.
많이 활용해보시면 좋을 것 같은데.
이 차트 분석 서비스.
한번 축하님 한번 보실래요?
솔직히 괜찮죠?
1차 지지선 19만원.
2차 지지선 17만원.
1차 저항 22만원.
2차 저항 22만 5천원.
그래서.
지지선 부근에서 매수해라.
분할 매수하라고 하는데.
정립식으로.
어때요?
왜냐면 우리 개인들은 사실.
이렇게 막.
손절 라인.
지지선 이런 걸 모르거든요.
손절해요?
아 이거 안됩니다.
아 이거 안돼요?
아직 그 정도.
매매 전략도 있네.
뒤에 있구나.
손절 라인 17만원.
하락 시.
손절 라인을 지켜봐라.
야 기술적 분석 있다.
뒤에 기술적 분석.
21, 61, 120표 알려주고.
이 정도는.
기본적으로 보고 해야 돼요.
사실.
우리가 안 볼 뿐이지.
우리가 공부를 해서.
이렇게 알면 좋은데.
그걸 못 할 경우에는.
지금 AI가 이렇게 알려주니까.
좋은 것 같아요.
어우 그럼요.
이게 기술적 분석 지식이 없어도.
요 차트를.
바탕으로.
분석을 해주기 때문에.
이해할 수 있도록.
도움을 주는.
그런 서비스고.
요 나무증권.
다 갖고 계시죠?
어 저는 사실.
응.
나무증권.
계좌가 없습니다.
아니 자네는.
몽둥이 좀 줘봤어요.
몽둥이.
이거는 자네가 안돼.
그러려고.
그건 고기롭구만.
지금 신규 개설하면.
갤럭시 폴드.
에어팟 맥스.
요런 이제.
상품 라인업이.
준비가 되어 있습니다.
그리고.
국내 주식.
100만원 이상 거래 시.
2만원 황금 이벤트도.
준비가 되어 있습니다.
국내 주식.
우대 수수료도.
이벤트도 있다 보니까.
투자하시면 어떨까 싶습니다.
자 그러면 오늘.
니니쌤 강의는.
여기까지 하도록.
하겠습니다.
뚱니.